foreign
right down the street here in Nashville
what's up Dave
hi uh thank you for this I just I really
appreciate the opportunity to talk to
you about this you got it man thank you
for for giving me a buzz man what's up
so I have a 17 year old son who's been
making some bad decisions lately
um my question is how to best help him
in general
and and specifically I'm wrestling with
whether or not to support him going away
to college this fall with everything
that's been going on in it
I don't mean that as a punishment I mean
as just trying to do what's best for him
and try to help
okay tell me some tell me more
okay so he has um a strong close family
history of addiction
he's very well aware of this
um about five months ago or so he got
caught using pot and um
he was caught again just a few weeks ago
and this time we see that he has some
really really bad grades as well
um
he has a good scholarship to a good
small private school and has a spot on
one of the sports teams there it seems
like a really good situation
for most 17 year olds going out to the
world
um
and I've asked him
what he wants to do from here like where
he wants to go and with where he's found
himself
um he says if there's anything he could
do there's no restrictions if you do
anything that he wanted to do he wants
to go to this school and go play on the
sports team
and we've had a lot of discussions about
how like these things that he's been
doing these decisions he's made are not
in line with that you know like kids
don't go on to college if they're
failing high school you know their
classes in high school
so
you know I'm scared
to send him I'm scared of sitting in a
month for failure
but I'm also scared to not send them and
and scared what would fill that void
um what he would do if he wasn't going
um
[Music]
I've had this conversation probably 5
000 times in my career and I I would hug
you if you were sitting with me right
now okay yeah um I know that the weight
of this feels so heavy and it feels like
some of these moments are either or we
get this one right or there's a whole
catastrophic ending to the left and we
get this wrong and right so it feels
like there's heaviness here so let's
pull back a little bit
um you said he's got a long history of
uh family addiction
um have you struggled with addiction
no no it's um it's nobody in his
immediate family
um his uncle grandfather grandfather's
brothers and it's it's
pretty profound stuff okay
um
Brothers uncles grandparents on your
side or on wife's side
on Mom's side okay what are y'all what
do you and Mom do for a living
uh we're both in healthcare okay both um
uh like Masters level uh Healthcare
Providers okay
um
great income good at what you do
uh
LED in and yeah yeah both pretty good at
what we do I'd say okay
um so the next couple things I'm gonna
say
I'm I'm fishing a little bit just
admittedly okay
and normally if you were and I were
sitting down for like a coaching session
we would talk for a couple hours but I'm
gonna get cut right to the Chase and I
need you to promise me you're not going
to take some of the things I say as
indictments of ways you have failed is
that cool right yeah totally
um when somebody tells me they have a
long generational history of addiction
the first thing that comes into my mind
is a long history of Performance Based
disconnection
a long history of Performance Based
the suckiest part about being a parent
of a 17 year old who smokes weed is that
weed works really well
especially on a young mind
it takes away that gnawing anxiety
you and I both know also that it kills
drive it kills sexual dysfunction it's
it's terrible for a developing brain all
those things we know that
but for a 17 year old it works
and so my question is always with a 17
year old not while you why are your
grades suddenly falling off why are you
suddenly smoking weed you got in trouble
and then also you're doing it again and
you've been doing it again
that's never my question my question is
always why are you hurting what about
your world
how are you in so much pain that this is
the only way
you can soothe that pain
see how there's a difference there
yeah I do
um let me tell you this and so I work
with really high performing families all
over the country have for years
and it was a revelation to me when I
found out that addiction can be really
hard drugs it can be heroin it can be
cocaine it could be all kind of things
then I learned it could be pornography
and sex
then I learned it could be 90 hour work
weeks
and it could be
we have to make this much money we have
to have this grades we have to have
clothes that look like this you got to
have cars that are clean like this and
the addiction becomes the
outer shell to Performance and these
things get carried on generationally not
always through if there's always cocaine
and heroin at some point that generation
ends
but somebody picks up that baton and
says oh I'll fix this
and their life becomes one of perfection
and performance and the addiction is the
same it's just that our culture gives
you a hundred fifty thousand dollars a
year for it
I I don't think I don't believe that
that's it and what you're saying is like
we're putting pressure on him to perform
I definitely don't think that's in line
with what we've done I'd say it's
probably more the opposite is that we
have really let the kids do whatever
they want to do you want to play this
sport they play the sport you don't want
to that's okay you want to work here
fine
we're not helicopter parents we're
honestly
the only reason we looked at his grades
is because we found him smoking weed
again
um
the the one I'd say the only the amount
of pressure that we give to the kids is
that with this one specifically
he does no homework at home he's
he's an awesome kid and uh but he does
he's not super studious and so the one
thing we said is like hey if you're not
going to be doing homework at home it
means your grades are good enough for
that so like 85 is minimum if you're if
you're over 85 great just you do you uh
if you're under 85 you're grounded
Monday through Friday because you should
be doing more homework and um so like
that's that that's the extent of our
yeah
pressure
um as far as to perform everything else
is just just him I mean he's he's going
to he wasn't going to play any sports in
school and he decided he wanted to go to
this one specific school and do this one
specific sport so
we're happy to support him in that
um but of course
he knows that part of that for us it's
like really just two three things we've
asked for is to be you know respectful
and pleasant to be around in the house
uh your grades need to be good enough
and to not do drugs you know that's
that's really it and
um
he's violated at least two out of the
three things probably more toward three
out of the three things
um just here lately
this has been a couple of weeks now
since since we caught him the second
time and he is trying he is
he's doing a bunch of catch-up work
trying to get his grades better they are
starting to turn the right direction
um he was
so like disappointed in himself but also
just mad at us because he didn't agree
with kind of the things we were doing
you know we were limiting his phone use
and that didn't make sense because he
didn't do anything wrong with his phone
he just was angry so angry I was trying
so hard to
that connects more with him because you
know he's 17 he's got the keys he's just
gone all the time
um and now he's home and grounded for
the most part
um
I want you to hear you found yourself on
a track okay sorry no no you're good
you're good man your dad that loves the
sun you found yourself on what I call a
21st century parenting trap uh it's a
loop
and I fall into it man so same team here
okay I got two young kids too they're
not 17 yet but they're on their way
foreign
so earlier I said I was fishing I'm
happy to hear that man that makes my
heart feel good
and here's what sucks about being a
parent
we can go too far the other way to where
we create a world that feels like
there's no boundaries until Wham there
are
and so you've got a kid like my first
question to you after that is how in the
world do you have a 17 year old and you
don't know what their grades are
and so I can absolutely see you and your
wife sitting down and saying hey we are
not going to be those parents that are
lunatics that are overbearing or
whatever
and then your 17 year old who's clearly
got smart parents probably has smart
brothers and sisters and I'm just
talking about me personally who I had an
older sister who was on the Academic
Decathlon team and my younger brother
missed like two questions on the ACT
then there was dumb jock in the middle
of me
I had great expectations but I didn't
know how to do that
I didn't know how to study I just was
told hey if you're not doing your work
you get your crap you better be better
be here I didn't know how to bridge that
Gap and then what you've done is you've
taken away the one thing that keeps a 17
year old brain stable which is
relationships
and so you see this toggle between a
lonely brain screaming for a
reconnection and the three things that
work for a young brain to to to
um uh duct tape over disconnection
alcohol marijuana sex
and look around at all of our kids
especially when they go to college
because we unplug them from their world
and we dropped them in a box and we say
make great choices together
and these are little brains saying I
just needed my I need my tribe I need my
gang and not getting these grades
is it you see what I'm saying so it
becomes this Loop and then he's going to
work really hard and he's really smart
he's going to get his grades up but you
know that I know that he's gonna get him
up and he's going to White Knuckle his
way to not smoking weed
so that he can finally get some Freedom
back and then his poor brain is going to
be screaming at that little 17 year old
boy with all it's got saying you got to
reconnect you gotta reconnect you gotta
reconnect and we're just gonna get on a
loop here
my recommendation the way to break the
loop is a couple fold
the first one is is less conversations
you all start doing stuff on the regular
together just you and him
and you can say like I already do that
like this is above and beyond this is
like I'm I'm I'm you have to go to
breakfast with me once a week or twice a
week and you got to go on walks with me
in the evening you just have to and that
anger is real and the anger is Justified
I get the anger and also it will
dissipate because it's a body saying
this isn't how it's supposed to be we're
supposed to be in relationship and it's
right now it's me versus my parents and
you need to show take that step because
you're the adult
no man I'm with you I'm with you I'm
with you I'm with you that's the set
first one the second one is
if there's a way to get teach him some
study skills or as a household from the
hours of this to this
the music's off and we all study that's
just the way this works my wife and I
set that up at our house like we're
we're a family full of nerds right
um so this isn't for everybody but we
just have reading time after after
school like people just plop down and
read and so it's it's kind of awkward to
not do that
um or my son will heads off into the
woods and runs around for himself
outside just to get get his wiggles out
we call him and then he comes back in
and we all just do homework for a season
and when I'm home I join in I do the
same thing but it's just a rhythm and a
routine it's not hey you got to figure
this stuff out because some 17 year olds
haven't figured that out and I'm one of
those kids and I guess I want you to see
down the road I didn't have I didn't
smoke weed in high school okay but I've
made stupid choices a lot of them
me too there's a lot of
okay so you're a perfect example like
I I
guess I wouldn't give up on this kid and
I know you're not but I I I will
you know him better than me
I'm always looking at trend lines is the
trend line heading down are we in
heading to some to some scary territory
or do we have a 17 year old who is
struggling who needed some boundaries
maybe different boundaries than his
brothers and sisters and we have to
shake the shake the snow globe a little
bit his grades are going to be fine and
maybe we're gonna have a conversation
with Coach maybe we're gonna have a
conversation with the school Counseling
Center and say hey we've struggled had
some struggles in the past we want him
to see you guys once a week hey coach I
want you to keep an eye on him and um
we're gonna watch really closely with
his grades I I don't necessarily think
that's an either ordeal I I personally
have seen kids get out of some of those
situations and really Blossom and I've
seen some extraordinary kids get their
butts kicked out of college right so
it's it's kind of bad I I definitely
feel like no matter what I decide with
what to do with him in the end it can go
either way just like you're saying and
that's the that's the suckiest part of
being a pair that's all of us right
yeah
yeah I'm scared that like because I I
can identify with him so well I made
lots of bad decisions and turned out
okay I really I feel like I turned out
okay yeah
um
but you know with I didn't have the
addiction family history stuff and I'm
I'm yeah but hey but listen Dave don't
put that on don't put that on him don't
put that on him because it's going to
become a self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah okay it's something to be aware of
but it's not prophetic it's not it's not
guaranteed it's not predetermined for
him
I've definitely been
trying like I do feel like he thinks
that we don't like him yeah we've been
trying to say like hey that's not true
you can't say it through all these
things you can't say like family dinners
it's like it's those were for you you
were the only one that wasn't here when
we said we have to be here for family
dinners it was so we could see you yeah
so I guess my question is that is it
okay to force yes the connection time
for a while because in general he wants
to be out and doing things with his
friends he wants to be going to play
this sport he wants to go to work so
he's never around yes
okay he's finding it somewhere else
he's finding it somewhere else what you
just touched on I think is
um probably one of the most under
understood issues with our kids
he doesn't feel like anybody likes him
but there's a group of people at school
that does
and weed makes that feeling of my family
doesn't like me I don't like them it
takes the edge off of that bird
just does just us
and so yes there is something to be said
for I'm your dad you're 17 you live in
my house you have to have breakfast
breakfast with me once a week
we're going to see this concert together
and I want you to come with me and just
dude I sat through a Garth Brooks show
it ended up being a good time that was
not for me it was for myself that was
for my son
the Turn Style show coming up this
Summer that one's for me but not the
Garth show but find some concerts in
town you're in Nashville for God's sake
dude there's one every weekend
but you're gonna spend some old man time
and here's the deal at one of those
breakfast
you can reach across the table and say
something like this I'm gonna make this
really weird for us for a second okay
hold my hand son
and have him look at you and say I love
you and I like you you're a great kid I
would prefer to spend time with you than
some of my knuckleheaded friends
and I haven't been doing a good job of
that
and so from this day forward it's going
to be weird because I'm gonna show you
that I like you and that I love you and
this house doesn't work without you
and that's a totally different
proposition you see what I'm saying
I do I get choked up just thinking about
having that conversation
yeah and then you can tell them
everything you want you can tell them
you can tell them you can tell them none
of that matters you gotta show it
you gotta show him and if you tell them
on your way to work and you tell them on
the way to a surgery you got to be a
part of and if you tell them on the way
to a dinner that he's not invited to
he's getting the message loud and clear
that he's kind of just in the way and he
just needs to get these grades and not
do this thing and everything's fine and
that's Performance Based connection
seeing that he's a priority on your
calendar seeing he's a priority in your
checkbook
and you are taking the step towards him
not just sitting there waiting for him
to come to you
now he's seeing Oh my dad likes me he
wants to spend time with me he laughs at
my jokes
I can't tell you how grateful I am to
have dads like you in my neighborhood
who love their sons like you do
and I need you to hear me say this is a
trap all of us fall into which is just
this Loop we gotta get paid we gotta we
have our lives we want to do our lives
and kids I just want you to make the
grades and don't go to jail and don't do
drugs why is it so hard
some of our kids fall right in line and
others say I need a little bit more I
experience the world different will you
just show me that you like me
that's hard
and that changes everything
thanks for the call my brother Dave call
anytime man come by and see me we can
hang out and have coffee here in the
lobby appreciate you man